[Applause]
well we're in the center of Quezon City
we're actually in a a particularly
residential area the prosecutor's office
is just to my left you can see the
Rescue Services are trying to go bit by
bit down areas that once were covered
roads in the center of the city to try
and find out if there are any stragglers
there are already hundreds
maybe thousands of people who have
already been evacuated to Odessa and
mikalaya
there are Red Cross Vans as you can see
and a lot of other volunteers circling
the flooded areas we are talking as you
said about
18 Cubit kilometers of water which has
been Unleashed and the flood waters have
been washing down uh slowly but surely
swallowing up about a hundred villages
and towns including hairson City the
capital of Pearson region